combien y at il des pav dans l'estuaire
du saint-laurent le fleuve saint laurent
au québec c'est l'un des plus grands
cours d'eau du monde et c'est aussi un
important cimetière marin parce qu'au
fil du temps il y a eu à cet endroit
plusieurs grands naufrages
1711 une flotte militaire britannique
qui transportent 12000 personnes met le
cap vers la nouvelle france pour
l'attaqué mais une grosse tempête se
lève huit bateaux coulent près de 900
personnes perdent la vie
l'attaqué est annulé
1914 le brouillard provoque une
collision entre les frères vanrullen d
un charbonnier norvégien au large de
rimouski la presse collante 14 minutes
1012 passagers membres d'équipage moeurs
1942 à 1945 durant la deuxième guerre
mondiale des sous marins allemands
s'aventure dans le saint laurent en
trois ans les youboat cool 23 navires
marchands et militaires
1963 le navire marchand très tonique a
sombré au large de petite rivière saint
françois
après une collision avec un autre
paquebot le bilan est lourd 33 marins
chinois périssent
on compare souvent l'île d'anticosti un
cimetière marin tout ça parce que de
nombreux naufrages s'y sont produits il
faut dire que les hauts-fonds autour de
l'île ont toujours été des pièges pour
les navigateurs à ce jour on peut donc
estimer à plus d'une centaine le nombre
d'épaves dans l'estuaire du saint
laurent mais les récits historiques
permet de croire que des centaines
d'autres bateaux gisent au fond du
fleuve